- Hello.
Hello, everybody!
Good afternoon and welcome to
"Autonomous Agents You Can Trust."
My name is Neil LeBlanc and I am with IBM
and I lead our go-to-market
for watsonx.governance.
- And my name is Diana
Griffin and I am with KPMG,
and I am focused AI governance
and I am part of the alliance with IBM.
- So hopefully you all didn't
get too stuffed at lunch,
but, if you did, then we're
here to keep you awake
and burn off some calories.
Look, you know, I think as
we look back over the course
of the last two or three years,
I don't think too many
people would've predicted
just how powerful or where
we would've gotten, right?
How AI would've evolved.
And especially as we kinda look at agents.
And you look around the expo floor,
you look through the thousands of sessions
that were in the catalog,
there's a lot about agents.
And as we kind of look
at how they've evolved
over the course of the last year or so,
they have certainly become more powerful
and it's expected that
they're gonna become
even more powerful and
even more sophisticated.
But it comes with some concerns, right?
It comes with some concerns around
what their potential impact is gonna be,
what some of the ethical
ramifications are gonna be,
and even what some of the impacts
on society are potentially gonna be.
And so as we kinda look at
the promise of agentic AI
and agents, you know, there's
been a number of talks
that I've listened to,
but they could be used in
a number of different ways.
Certainly they could be used
to effectively help humans
perform tasks and achieve
business outcomes.
And they could be used to augment
human intelligence, right?
We think we're smart, they're
smarter, but they can help us,
if they're used in the right way.
They can help automate a
lot of some of the mundane
and the time consuming tasks
that we typically have done
over the course of the last little while.
They can help improve
efficiency and productivity,
and they can also help us
improve our decision making
as well as the quality of the
responses that we're given.
You know, there are studies
that come out all the time
and, you know, this is
an example of three,
and I think if we probably
wait a week or two weeks
or three weeks, we're
gonna get more studies.
But you kinda look and the
first one was something
that McKinsey had come out
with that said, you know,
agentic AI and agents
are gonna help contribute
to an added value of about $4.4
trillion of profit annually.
And if you look at something
that the BCG had come out with,
they recognize that
agents are here to stay
and that they're gonna
lead to an expansion
of about 45% growth over the
course of the next five years.
And Gartner has said that, basically,
by 2028 one-third of
all of our interactions
with generative AI, with Gen
AI, is gonna be through the use
of action models or
through autonomous agents.
Agents are everywhere!
Again, walk around the show floor
and everyone's talking about agents.
It's not that they're only everywhere,
it's that they come from everywhere.
And they don't know where.
You know, organizations
are faced with a dilemma
where they're struggling
to get a handle on
where did they originate?
Who built them?
How were they tested?
What data were they tested on?
And that's a concern,
because they don't know what is being used
within an organization.
And so, when we look at...
When we talk to our customers,
and Diana and I will talk
about this in a little bit,
but as we look at our
customers and talk to them
about their AI strategy,
obviously, they want
to get as much a return
out of their AI as possible,
but that's only gonna be possible
if there's good governance,
if there's good AI
governance also put in place.
And so when we look at
some of the reasons why
governance is critical, one
of the things that, you know,
if we look probably
two or three years ago,
it was probably a lot easier,
maybe three to five years,
it was probably a lot
easier to understand,
when we were looking at
traditional and predictive ML,
how many models were being used,
what were the use cases that
they were being used for?
Then we saw Gen AI and the RAD use cases,
and we started to lose track.
We started to figure out,
okay, well, we know potentially
what LLMs, what foundation models we have,
but we don't know what the use cases are.
We don't know what all
the prompt templates are.
And so we started to lose sight.
Now with agentic, it's getting
even more apparent, right?
We're losing the transparency
into who's building them,
how they're being built,
where they're being built,
and how they're being trained.
And that's cause for some concern as well.
The inability to explain behavior.
Again, when it was
traditional predictive ML,
you kind of knew that the
models were gonna run,
they were gonna spit some
outcome or output out.
Even with Gen AI,
there was kind of some
human in the loop, right?
There was.
Somebody would put in a prompt,
would get a response back,
and go, no, that doesn't look right,
and was able to make a decision.
With agents, especially
with multi agentic systems,
as they start to talk to each other,
and as they become autonomous,
the inability to understand
the decisions that were made,
the lack of explainability
is a major concern.
And there's still some challenges
around manual error-prone testing.
There's even more concern
around bias, around drift,
just around the general health
and the quality of agents.
And then there's a number
of disparate tools.
And, of course, not to
mention sort of the lack
of those guardrails, right?
Those safe safety guardrails
that are put in place
to ensure that they're behaving the way
that they're supposed to behave
and that they're being used
the way that they're supposed to behave.
So, as we kind of look
at watsonx.governance,
we kind of...
Not kind of, but we look at how to address
some of these concerns
and some of these risks.
So, the first thing that
we kinda look at is,
how do we start the whole observability?
How do we monitor the agents
for their performance?
How do we know that they are performing
the way that they're supposed to perform?
How do we know that they're producing
the output that they're
supposed to produce?
And this is a continuous monitor,
continuously monitoring and
raising those alarm bells
if something should happen.
There's the evaluation
capabilities, right?
Evaluating at build time, at testing time,
and continuously evaluating
even when they're in production,
and ensuring that the
same quality is adhered to
while in production that
was met when prior to them
being deployed into production.
And then the last is,
it's not just good enough
to understand the behavior.
It's not good enough to
just understand the score
and the results that are coming out,
but it's about the optimization.
How do you know what is the
right agent to do for the job?
How do you know if something
is starting to fail?
If the quality, if it's
starting to hallucinate,
how do I go back and fix it?
What are the steps that I need to take?
So, these are some
capabilities that we look at
with watsonx.governance.
And I'm just gonna walk through
kind of a quick demo here.
It's only about a minute and a half.
Maybe I shouldn't say quick.
Maybe I should say lightning
since this is a lightning round.
But let me just set up
the demo real quick.
We could remove that placeholder.
Mark did confirm with me,
so it is the latest one.
But what we're about to
see is a scenario where
somebody wants to onboard a new use case
for a banking tooling.
And as part of that use case,
they wanna onboard a new agent.
And so what we're gonna go through
and we're gonna identify the use case
and identify some risks.
So, again, just setting this up,
it is gonna go a little bit quick,
but, basically, what
we're looking at here,
this is watsonx.governance and this is
what we call the Governance Console.
This is kind of the landing page
and this gives you sort
of that landscape of AI
and how it's being deployed
across the organization.
So, this is gonna go quick,
but, basically from this area,
we're able to start drilling down
and getting into the details.
Now we can start seeing
the inventory of the agents
that have been onboarded
within my organization,
within my department,
within my enterprise.
We can drill down even further
to start looking at some of the metadata.
We can see who built
it, when was it built,
what is the purpose, so on and so forth.
The other area is around
being somewhat risk averse.
So, within watsonx.governance,
we have the ability
through what we call a questionnaire
to ask a series of questions.
Now, this is a bit of a cooking show,
so we're not gonna go through
and answer all 60 questions,
but we're gonna get to
the outcome real quick.
So, based off of the
responses to the questions,
it'll automatically
identify what are the risks
that we need to be concerned with,
how do we go and mitigate those risks,
what are the controls that
we need to put in place,
and how do we have an audit that we know
that we've actually
taken the necessary steps
and the appropriate actions to
mitigate some of those risks
and document that,
so, when auditors come in, they'll know
what steps have been taken.
So, all of this could happen before
we either onboard a new agent
or do it at the time of the use case
to understand here's the
use case, here's the desire,
here's what we actually want to do.
Here are the agents or the assets,
it doesn't necessarily
need to be a single agent,
it could be multiple,
here are the agents that we want to use,
the assets we want to use.
And then we combine the two,
so we understand what the use case is,
what are the agents, and it
might be one or multiple,
and that same agent might be
used on multiple use cases.
So, understanding the
relationship between them.
And then last, as we're going through this
and understanding sort
of the risk posture,
and then as we get into the
approval, it's now saying,
yes, I approve this,
let's go ahead and approve this use case
and onboard the the agents.
So, a bit of a shameless plug.
You know, analysts agree
that watsonx.governance
has been recognized as one of the leaders
as part of AI governance.
And so, with that, I think, you know,
let's have a conversation
about what we just saw,
what I was just talking about.
So, quickly, Diana, I think
one of the things that.
We've heard that governance kind of has
this sort of notion that
it's more of a hindrance,
more of a hurdle.
I'm curious to get what
is your take on that?
- So, I think that we
should look at AI governance
as guardrails and not as a blocker.
Traditionally governance
is seen as a blocker,
but when we think of
it as how do we adopt?
A lot of organizations
don't know how to get going
and they're using the lack of a plan
or the lack of guardrails as an inhibitor.
And so when you actually
put governance in place
and you put thoughtful governance in place
on what you are going to accept,
it allows your innovation to accelerate.
Organizations and your innovative people
now know what they need to do
in order to get those use cases passed.
A tool such as WatsonX
allows you to build it in,
have use cases already approved,
so a developer can go in and say,
I can start from this use case,
I can use this type of code,
I know that will get approved,
and go through the workflow
and get it approved quicker.
I have clients who have really great ideas
and they're really excited for them,
and they take nine months
to be even able to get
the AI agent idea approved
before they can even start to build,
because they don't know
what the governance is.
By having strong and clear
governance guardrails,
it accelerates innovation.
So we need to change our paradigm
on how we look at governance.
And by using a tooling,
it allows us to share that information
and create a streamlined
approach to getting it approved
and monitoring it.
- Yeah, I think that you're
a hundred percent right
that so many people were nervous
and saw governance as
being sort of that blocker,
but, really, it can help accelerate
and help generate the
return on investment.
- Yeah!
- On the AI investment
that customers have have made.
- When you don't know the governance
and you don't know how to adopt it,
it actually prohibits
people from innovating
and also encourages them to build it
on the side of their desk.
You don't know what's going
on in your environment
and you're increasing your risk profile.
So, you really need...
You don't want shadow AI.
You want people to create this.
You don't want to actually stop them.
People think, oh, if I
don't tell them how to do it
or if I don't give them governance,
then they're not going to do it.
They're doing it anyway.
So you want to provide those guardrails
and provide people with an
instruction manual of sorts
in order to know how to
accelerate their innovation.
- What are you seeing as
some of the challenges
that customers are seeing in
terms of being able to adopt
or implement governance,
implement those processes,
implement the practices and so on.
And, by the way, we only have
seven and a half minutes, so.
- Okay. (laughing)
So, some of the things
that I personally see
is they don't know...
They don't even know
what they're looking at.
This is all happening fast.
No one necessarily is
an expert in this space.
People just have maybe a few
more at bats than others.
So, they don't know what
to do, so they don't do it.
They hide their head in the sand.
That's one thing.
We don't know who is the
AI governance committee.
We don't know who the right people are,
so they can't make a decision
because there's no consensus.
The old ways of working no longer work.
And so they don't wanna trust it,
they think 'cause they don't
have the risks assessment,
and they don't have all these things,
they're just gonna be able to stop it.
You're not stopping it!
So, you're not governing it,
you don't know what the words are,
and you don't know how to get going,
so you're just not doing it.
But that's exposing your
organization to so much risk.
- Yeah, I think, you know, if you...
There was a funny story
where you're in a boardroom
and you ask a group of people,
whose responsibility is
it for AI governance?
Everybody would look around and go,
well, maybe that person, but,
at the end, it's everybody's.
- Everybody, yeah!
- And, you're right that they
don't know how to get started.
Absolutely!
What are you seeing, how do
you see sort of the agentic
and agents sort of increasing
the need for agentic?
- I think that with the increase
and the promise of agentic and agents,
it makes AI governance
even more important,
because you need to know that that agent
is now autonomous, potentially,
is actually doing what it
says it's supposed to do.
And through a tool like WatsonX,
you can monitor it for drift,
you can monitor it for bias,
you can actually set these
thresholds and understand,
is my agent performing?
Is it doing what I said
it's supposed to do?
Is it acting in the use case
that I've designed it to?
And is it continuing to perform?
It allows you to get out
of pencils and spreadsheets
and allows you to have
a better understanding
that it is actually doing
what it says it's going to do.
I think that's so
important with the invent,
with agents and the adoption of agents,
especially agents doing
agents on upon agents.
If you don't have a governance tooling,
how do you know what's happening?
And with the dashboard
you can see if it pops up
if there's a problem.
- Yeah, I just think that the whole
autonomous nature of things
and not knowing, as you said,
sort of the agents on top of agents.
And, you know, like I said before,
if you put a prompt in,
if you ask a question,
sort of the Gen AI, the RAD use case,
you get a response back, as a human,
you can make a decision-
- Yes.
- About whether or not
it's the right response.
With agents, if you make a small mistake
on that initial agent that's
calling the second one-
- Yes!
- It's just gonna continue
to get amplified.
Absolutely!
- Absolutely!
- Is there anything in specific that you,
or could guide or advise the audience on
when assessing agents
and looking for different
kinds of agents to be used?
- So, when I look across the landscape,
I start with a process
and I identify where the pain
points are in your process
and I focus on outcomes.
I know, probably, a lot
of people talk about this,
but you should not automate your tasks
and the specific things you're doing now.
You wanna look across your
landscape of your process
and identify where your opportunities are
and then automate that outcome level.
And then you can have
agents automating on top,
monitoring that to make sure
it's performing as planned,
but you don't want to just
automate your bad process.
Like, when I used to do
software development,
people would say, I really
want this red button.
They didn't really want the red button.
That was their pain point.
Don't automate that red button.
Look at what your outcome needs to be
and that's how you can
design and build your agents.
- Okay.
Any sort of last thoughts
that you wanted to share
that I didn't ask you about, or?
- I think, to me, one of the
things I'm most excited about
as adopting and looking across this is
how you can get so much more with this.
This is no longer prompt
engineering or machine learning.
Those were ways...
You could have done those things
using your traditional means.
With the evolution of where we sit today,
you have to think about
an AI governance tool.
If you don't have an AI
governance tool in place,
it's going to make it really
difficult for you to know
that the agents you're
installing in your building
are actually performing, you're
getting the value from them,
and you don't have a bunch of people
building things on their desk
that are now in your system
that expose you to penetration,
expose you to bias,
or other things that could cause
a lot of risk into your environment.
And I think that a tooling
helps you understand
what you're building,
what you're deploying.
IBM WatsonX is hybrid for purpose, open,
so it's not telling you
how to build your agents,
it's not telling you
what tooling it can do.
It can monitor your entire environment.
I think it's a really strong platform
that really opens you up to
accelerate your innovation.
- Great, perfect, thank you.
So, I think, with that,
there's a couple of things,
so, obviously, we're working
on watsonx.governance,
on delivering out a development
kit around AgentOps.
And we have a booth back
there with a big IBM sign,
and there's a big bumblebee outside.
So, with that, thank you
very much for your time today
and enjoy the rest of the conference.
- [Diana] Thank you.
(audience applaud)